il faut qu'on se parle il ya quelques
jours je vous ai parlé d'un smartphone
que j'attendais depuis quelques temps
c'était le xiaomi me disent pro le
nouveau modèle très haut gamme de chez
home il ya une grosse montée en gamme
ses chiots me avec un smartphone qui
vient flirter avec les mureaux et lors
de la présentation xiaomi également
présenté un autre modèle pas
professionnel le modèle un peu plus
standard sans réellement lettre c'est
lui dise aujourd'hui on va donc se
tester ce me disent voir quelles sont
les réelles différences entre le 1010
pro et le lui dise et vous allez voir
qui en fait quatre points de différence
ont tout le reste qui est semblable je
vous renvoie à ma vidéo d'une milice pro
puisque vous êtes déjà tout dit on va
donc se concentrer sur les différences
avant toute chose vous le savez on en
période de confinement alors à laquelle
je tourne la vidéo et pendant le
confinement je vais demander à envoyer
vos vidéos savoir comment ça se passait
chez vous on va donc sans regarder la
vidéo du jour
salut la communauté moi c'est williams
et ben voilà petit baladeur quotidienne
de une heure car j'ai la chance
d'habiter en campagne on n'a rien autour
de nous comme pu le constater c'est très
calme des vignes voilà c'est joli
on prend l'air ça fait du bien une heure
par jour on a la chance d'être en
campagne donc du coup on peut profiter
ça ce n'est pas qu'à de vous qui êtes en
ville voilà je vous souhaite un bon
courage
pendant ce confinement mois l'arrêt du
cancer
jeux vidéo vidéo de monsieur grippe y
voilà au fait ce qu'on peut pour passer
que genre prenez soin de vous de votre
entourage
salut merci à toi pour cette vidéo on va
donc se concentrer tout de suite sur le
nouveau sur me milices le premier point
différence va se situer au niveau du
design c'est pas évident lorsque vous le
regardez comme ça parce que le design
est vraiment vraiment vraiment signal
mais une différence et elle se situe ici
au niveau du dos vous n'avez pas un vert
mat comme sur le modèle professionnel
vous avez un vert brillant qui prend
très facilement les traces de doigts
vous me direz peut-être c'est du point
de détail mais néanmoins je peux vous
assurer que je préfère quand même le
vert mat
la deuxième différence va être au niveau
de la batterie
ici vous avez une batterie de 4780
millan paire eur contre 4500 me
antérieures pour le modèle professionnel
il ya effectivement une différence au
niveau de l'autonomie
grosse différence surtout se faire au
niveau de la recharge ici vous n'avez
pas de recharge rapide extrêmement
rapide vous avez quand même de la
recharge rapide 30 watts
il n'y a pas de recharge 50 watts 65
watts il ya uniquement de la recharge 30
watts
que ce soit en filaire ou sans fil et
dans les deux cas cela ira très bien
sinon on retrouve également de la
recharge un verset 5 watts et côté
autonomie votre smartphone vous pour
regarder entre une journée et demie à
deux jours selon le visage le troisième
point c'est plus gros point la plus
grosse différence c'est toute la partie
photo
il ya deux éléments qui ne change pas
entre le modèle professionnel et le
modèle standard c'est le module photo
principal camp pour appeler le grand
angle on a un capteur de 100 8
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 1.69 qui vous
permettra voir technologie 4 pixels en
main pour capter plus de lumière et que
je trouve vraiment excellent sens du
discours
le deuxième point qui ne change pas
c'est l'appareil photo pour les selles
fille en un capteur de 20 mégapixels tu
ouvre à f 2.3 les deux sont très bons et
je vous donc le résultat dans quelques
instants
maintenant ya quelques différences et
qui sont vraiment notable vous avez un
ultra grand angle sur le modèle pro vous
aviez un 20 mégapixels qui ouvrait af
2.6 ici vous avez un 13 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.4
bon ok pourquoi pas sauf que et c'est la
grosse différence la macro sur le modèle
professionnel est géré par l' ultra
grand angle c'est pour la macro vous
avez un capteur de 5 mégapixels et vous
à quelque chose qui marche extrêmement
bien
tandis qu'ici la macro est géré par un
capteur de 2 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.4 et ça en règle générale je suis
vraiment pas fan
on va regarder les résultats dans
quelques instants vous aviez deux
téléobjectifs vous en aviez un premier
de 8 mégapixels qui vous permettait
d'avoir un zoom optique x 5 et vous en
aviez de 12 mégapixels qui vous
permettait d'avoir un zoom optique x 2
et c'est ici que se gérer notamment les
faits évoqués le mode portrait pour
avoir le flou d'arrière plan tandis
qu'ici vous l'avez avec un capteur de 2
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.4 alors dans
l'absolu pourquoi pas ça peut être bien
pour notre portrait sauf que c'est le
modèle professionnel vous avez un petit
laser c'est la caméra tough qui va
mesurer la distance entre vous et le
fond pour vraiment vous détacher et
appliquer un flou parfait ici on n'a pas
du tout cette technologie ça fonctionne
vraiment différemment donc on s'attend à
avoir un mode portrait de moins bonne
qualité après ce que vous
beaucoup de mains portrait ça c'est la
question à se poser on se regarde le
résultat dans quelques instants
ce qu'on voit donc ici et qui est
extrêmement intéressant c'est que pour
les photos standard vous avez votre
capteur de 100 8 mégapixels qui marchera
parfaitement bien par contre c'est lui
qui vous permettra d'avoir un zoom x 2
hybride vous ne passerez absolument pas
par des capteurs dédiés dont vous aurez
une qualité moindre
et vous pourrez aller uniquement jusqu'à
du x 10 on va se garder une fois de plus
le résultat dans quelques instants
l' ultra grand-angle pourquoi pas on a
une différence de capteurs on est
différent d'ouverture par contre la
macro sans papiers ça me tente pas
énormément
on voit qu'il ya une vraie différence en
termes de photos pourraient venir
également filmé en hulk a jusqu'à 30
images par seconde
je suis sûr que ça ne sert absolument
rien ce que je vous conseille si c'est
de venir filmer en full hd parce que
vous aurez une superbe stabilisation
exactement comme sur le modèle
professionnel
on va donc se regarder les résultats de
la photo jusqu'au cerveau pour me dire
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire voilà les photos faites avec
le xiaomi me disent on est sur la caméra
principale c'est exactement la même
qu'on va retrouver sur le me disent pro
et on voit que le rendu une fois de plus
est vraiment à la hauteur on passe
ensuite sur le très grand-angle je veux
montrer notre exemple quelques instants
et je trouve pas ça complètement fou
ensuite on passe sur un zoom hybride
fois deux on obtient cette photo en
partant du capteur principal et on vient
krupp et dans l'image on a un résultat
qui est quand même vraiment à la hauteur
on se rapproche ensuite avec le x 10 et
la réussite à tout de suite est beaucoup
moins bon caméra principale ça fait le
boulot
l' ultra grand-angle qui conviendra ici
on se rapproche en x 2 et on continue en
faut 10 et là c'est pas extraordinaire
caméra principale c'est vraiment bien
voler toutes les feuilles matoub détails
rien est cramé on a bien les nuages dans
le ciel on a bien tout l'effet de tous
les côtés on voit également bien les
zones un peu plus haut la caméra
principale est vraiment extrêmement
bonnes l'ultra grand-angle fait
néanmoins le boulot zuffa 2 c'est
extrêmement qualitatif dès qu'on se
rapproche chaque fois 5 on récupère
beaucoup de brouilly salissent c'est pas
extraordinaire il faut disent non plus
c'est pas terrible mais une fois de plus
le smartphone n'est pas vraiment adapté
pour aller jusqu'aux la regarder mon
niveau de la caméra principales dates
toutes les feuilles tous les détails
c'est vraiment hyper qualitatif on passe
sur le trac van tol alors on le voit ici
là c'est un petit peu cramé nova tout
très grand-angle n'est pas à la hauteur
de la caméra principale on vient se
rapprocher en ce moment c'est très très
très bon le x 5 pas extraordinaire et il
faut 10 une fois de plus c'est pas
terrible non plus caméra principale ça
fait le taff et dès qu'on passe sur le
très grand-angle bien récupérer toute
une zone cramer la gestion des hautes
lumières sous le très grand-angle et
extraordinaire le x 2 est très très bon
et dès qu'on se rapproche un peu plus
c'est pas extraordinaire
on va regarder la macro maintenant la
macro
sur une caméra de 2 mégapixels je suis
pas hyper enthousiaste je trouve pas ça
complètement dingue on récupère quand
même pas mal de bruit ici lors dès qu'on
a beaucoup de lumière ça va beaucoup
mieux mais dès que l'on à un tout petit
peu moins voyez tout de suite c'est pas
terrible terrible
elle est vraiment regarder la vidéo sur
le midi ce projet voudrait que la
qualité de la macro c'est quand même
d'autres choses tout à fait pas mal de
photos en macro mots il ya un petit
effet au waou
c'est pas dingue mais malgré tout ça
fait le boulot je suis pas hyper hyper
qu'on va vous convient d'utiliser de la
macro là dessus je suis pas hyper hyper
convaincu du résultat néanmoins ce quand
même plutôt sympa la caméra selphy
fonctionne c'est exactement la même que
sur les dix pros alors là je suis
vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment
dubitatif l'armée sur le mode portrait
et là je vous rends pas ce qui se passe
le mode portrait / exposé mais sur
exposé énormément là il ya beaucoup de
soleil mais regardez c'est cramé de tous
les côtés j'ai du mal à comprendre
j'ai vraiment voulu faire la différence
en faisant une photo avec le capteur
principal et ensuite j'ai shooté en mode
portrait et voiliers l'expo n'est pas du
tout la même
s'assure exposé je sais vraiment pas ce
qui s'est passé là dessus et pour moi
c'est pas voulu tu en protéines est ici
sur la photo de nuit à une fête plus
chou que schumi a vraiment fait un très
très bon boulot au niveau de la photo
nuit croyez-moi on n'était pas en pleine
journée on pourrait le croire
j'ai fait cette photo était quelque
chose comme 21h40 21h35 la nuit tombée
il faisait quasiment nuit
et autant vous dire que on n'y voyait
pas grand chose hélas le résultat est
vraiment quand même extrêmement bluffant
j'ai pris la photo de l'autre côté on a
l'impression qu'ils firent jour
l'impression que le ciel est bleu alors
que globalement pas du tout troisième
photo toujours plus dans les mêmes
conditions et voiliers résultat une fête
plus est sans appel
vous voyez qu'on a deux smartphones qui
sont vraiment extrêmement similaires
dans les deux cas du bluetooth cinq
points du wifi 6 du nfc veulent
infrarouge de la 5g enfin on a la même
fiche technique mais malgré tout il
reste une 4e différence et cette
différence c'est le prix juste ici vous
êtes à 799 euros virgule 90 dans la
configuration 8 gigas de ram plus sans
plus 256 giga de stockage presse que ce
soit un modèle professionnel vous êtes à
999 points 90 à dire quasiment à mi
longs ce qui faut bien retenir ici c'est
qu'avec le médicis vous aurez les mêmes
usages que mes dix pros avec une partie
photo
meaney et avec la même expérience
multimédia puisque vous avez même écran
puisque vous avez exactement la même
chose au niveau de l'audio avec des
performances très très très similaire
puisque vous avez un résultat surtout de
584 1495 alors vous aviez un résultat
sans modèle professionnel pour les noter
là dessus je n'ai pas pris par coeur de
594 me 242 autant dire que ce smartphone
se classe en deuxième place sur un
classement en tout autant vous dire que
xiaomi avant léman bien réussi sa copie
en terme de performance on a donc
commencé le meilleur du midi ce pro en
faisant quelques coupes au niveau de la
photo tu donc si vous voulez un
excellent smartphone au niveau
d'expérience multimédia que ce soit pour
naviguer sur internet pour les réseaux
sociaux pour jouer à des jeux même des
jeux franchement gourmands si vous
voulez un smartphone pré pour l'avenir
avec la 5g qu'il ya du wifi 6fa
smartphone extrêmement complet qui n'ira
pas aussi loin que le modèle
professionnel au niveau de la photo vous
aurez un capteur principal qui marchera
très bien c'est vraiment le gros point
fort leur s c'est quand même un petit
peu en dessous et bien le midi peut
vraiment être fait pour vous moi je
trouve vraiment bien
une fois de plus et ja 10 par rapport
aux milices pro si on m'y a fait
vraiment une très très belle montée en
gamme cette année les prix sont montés
également mais une fois de plus il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut
si vous voulez un smartphone moins cher
ou impliquez vous trouverez mais là par
contre ils ont montré les muscles et
centrait fort a vous de me dire
maintenant vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire et quant à nous on
trouve extrêmement rapidement pour
continuer à parler qu'à calais il me
faudra beaucoup d'amour à très très vite
[Musique]
m
et oh
[Musique]